and before we go  one more look back at the life and  career of supreme court justice ruth  bader ginsburg look at her face can't  get enough here are a few memorable  moments  using her own words  i ruth vader ginsburg do  solemnly swear i  surely would not be in this room today  without the determined efforts  of men and women who kept dreams of  equal citizenship  alive so  the question that's put to me is  now year three when do you think  there will be enough  when there are nine i would like  to show my granddaughters  that the equal citizenship stature of  men and women  is a fundamental human right it should  be  right up there with free speech  i wish there were a way i could wave a  magic wand  and put it back when people  were respectful of each other  and the congress was working for the  good of the country and not  just the long party lines